so
the queue is returning for picard series
2. one of my favorite characters from
all of the next generation
but where the hell is the most important
character where the hell is the
character that trekkies really love the
most
where's the enterprise sir there's
another starship coming in
it's the enterprise
[Music]
so could the enterprise e actually
appear in star trek picard series 2 what
does the canon and the beta cannon tell
us about whether this is possible or not
and i've got a little bit of a theory
which makes me a little bit excited that
either the e or maybe even the f
could appear in star trek card and why i
think
it needs to
engage
so first of all the enterprise e and why
it's my favorite starship
so
let's go over some of the details 685
meters long 250 meters wide 24 decks
depending on the movie it seems to me uh
picard says there's 24 decks in the
first film in first contact later in the
movie wharf says that um deck 26 and um
below has been assimilated by the borg
and then in star trek nemesis riker goes
down to deck 29 to have a fight with a
riemann so 24 decks
ish
she was the most advanced starship built
and she is just stunning
[Music]
if you are new to the channel please
like and subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll see all of our new content
i remember when i went to see star trek
first contact this was you know in the
90s there wasn't that much internet we
hadn't seen a lot of images of the
enterprise what we had seen was really
small so we were all really excited to
see the new enterprise
i actually went to this um
all night star trekathon basically where
they showed all the movies on the cinema
back to back
and i was still pretty young at this
point so i've never actually seen five
or six of the films um actually
undiscovered country was the first star
trek film i'd ever seen at the cinema
so i was
buzzing for this might have had a bit of
a nap during final frontier where they
go meet god um that was about three
o'clock in the morning i think i'd be
forgiven
who am i
don't you know aren't you god he
has his doubt
you doubt me
seek proof
jim
you don't ask the almighty for his id
then here is the proof
before first contact's official release
so we got to see first contact before a
lot of other people
and when they have that sweeping shot
that shows the enterprise for the first
time
there was an audible gasp in the
audience people went oh
we love the ship from day one and it is
designed beautifully
so do we actually know
canon
about where the enterprise e is right
now during picard
well we know the enterprise z was
launched in 2372 and in 2379
it fought against the scimitar
[Music]
[Music]
in 2381 captain picard became an admiral
and left the enterprise now we don't
officially know who then became captain
but some beta cannon suggests it was
captain data or captain wharf
or possibly both we know the picard
series happens in 2399
by this point the enterprise is barely
27 years old now
starfleet has always built its starships
in a sort of a modular fashion they can
be retrofitted really easily really
simply
i imagine the enterprise e was very
heavily refit following the battle with
the scimitar
after it basically ass handed to it
auxiliary power to forward shields hi
sir
so is there any reason to think that the
enterprise would have been retired by
the time 2399 came along
i don't think so and it wouldn't make
any real sense to
and we know from lots of star trek
series that ships come back again and
again and again
[Music]
how many times we see excelsior class or
even constitution class in deep space
nine these vessels are constantly refit
constantly upgraded and we see them
have very long lives within the
federation which kind of also makes
sense you would maybe
pull them back and not make them front
line ships but the federation is so fast
policing it must be an absolute freaking
nightmare
so is it possible and from what we know
about the law
that either the e or as i teased the f
could appear in picard
well according to the beta cannon
data was the captain of the enterprise e
following um the b4 download so actually
technically b4 is the captain of the
enterprise e um but with data in control
anyway
there's lots of storylines mainly from
star trek online about what then
happened to the e um including battles
with the species a472 or the undyne
um actually the final battle for the
enterprise e
uh was actually against the undyne the
enterprise e went into fluidic space
according to beta cannon
they were successful but the enterprise
was very heavily damaged and that was
the final
voyage of the enterprise e
again according to the beta cannon the
enterprise f was then launched in 2409.
data was initially offered the captaincy
but declined it instead offering it to
another group of crew that he
specifically suggested
so according to the beta cannon the
enterprise f was actually only launched
five years after the events of the first
series of picard
now picard being an android
um we don't actually know how long has
passed between series one series two it
could be that we're in this sort of time
frame where the enterprise f is being
launched
or there's another interesting
possibility
we're also if they go with this beta
cannon of the enterprise fb and launched
around this period we're in the kind of
time frame where the enterprise e could
have been destroyed
for me it doesn't make any sense that
the vessel would be retired
again less than 30 years old at the time
it was constructed it was the most
advanced starship ever built unless
there has been some sort of massive leap
in warp technology or transwarp
technology that basically means this
vessel is just completely out class and
outdated now there'd be no reason for
actually be retired in that case the
only reason we would see a new
enterprise the enterprise f
in 2409 as if the enterprise is
destroyed
could it be destroyed in picard series
2. a little bit a little bit really
quickly on the enterprise f because this
is actually a ship i had door the design
actually came from star trek online
there was a competition to design the
next enterprise and this design one
it's the or a modified version of this
design one
the class ship is actually the odyssey
now it's important to mention that
because there is another little tidbit
and another hint that maybe we could
actually see the enterprise f in picard
because of the graphic novel series
countdown the run-up to the series
picard premiere
so normally the comics and graphic
novels of enterprise are way off canon
they're a million miles away from it to
be honest and we don't have to take them
too seriously
but
in this case the countdown comics
actually seem to
be incorporated into the series picard
series actually seems to be taking them
quite seriously there are lots of story
elements that are explained in the comic
book that then are drawn through the
series
so in that case how important is it that
we actually see an odyssey-class
starship in the comics
is that a big hint
from the creators of the series that
we're going to see in enterprise but
maybe not the enterprise we already know
and love i think there is a big reason
why this is more than possible
and it's basically because of this scene
[Music]
when they basically shoehorned
this
whole scene into the end of the movie it
was a very last minute edition
there are hundreds of ships in that
scene and they're almost all identical
there are basically two slight design
changes a couple of their warping cells
are different other than that the ship
is exactly the same
and the ship riker is
captaining
wherever the real captain of that
starship is we don't actually know is
they're just hanging around with only
first officer waiting for a captain to
turn up i don't know
but the cheng hay that raga is
commanding is apparently the fastest
toughest vessel the fleet is ever put
into service
but it looks like a piece of crap
general or commodore or whatever you're
calling yourself right now i'm on the
bridge of the toughest fastest most
powerful ship starfleet has ever put
into service and i've got a fleet of
them at my back
so
i don't know here you can see it
compared to other starships it seems to
me that it's incredibly badly designed
look at the size of that shuttle bay in
the front of it for example it's as wide
as the enterprise a
what on earth is in there that they need
a shuttle bay that big
um
it just seems to be very quickly thrown
together but
seriously i mean it when it's like have
they never met a trekkie before
do they not know that we as the the true
fans the people that really watch this
series
obsess
on things like this and we love the
starships
how did they not write in
actually
seeing starfleet more in this series we
never really see it we never really see
any starships really
discovery in series 3 knew not to do
that when we got into the starfleet
federation
headquarters we see several ships in the
background including the nog which i'd
love that little nod to deep some really
interesting starship designs that we
have obsessed over
we see them enough as well that we can
actually have a good look at them
in this scene we don't really see
anything
the the view of the of this new ship
this new shanghai is is really
kind of blurry and
distant and you don't really see
anything it's bayonet and that is mainly
because it's a scene that was really
thrown together last second this wasn't
going to originally be in picard it was
kind of something they realized last
minute if we don't do something like
this the fans are going to have our
necks because they rushed it
the fans were never happy with this
scene it never worked really in the
episode and it was the biggest
disappointment of the picard series
that is why i think we could actually
see the enterprise in picard series 2 or
maybe series 3. they know star trek fans
were annoyed particularly by this scene
however much we love the picard series
this scene really let us down
and a lot of fans have been shouting
where is the federation in this series
we want to see the federation
they also must know
trekkies obsess on things like this
have a look on youtube and how many
videos are done about the different
starships of the federation looking at
how many decks there are how many things
weapon systems and
we love this thing i love this sort of
thing
so in that case
that is why
if i was the creator of star trek picard
i would be figuring out how to put the
enterprise either the e
or actually kind of i hope the f
into star trek card because
it's the only way you're going to get
some of us back online so if you are new
to the channel and you are because it's
a new channel please like and subscribe
we talk about everything sci-fi we're
going to be watching alongs with sci-fi
episodes sci-fi movies we're going to be
doing news when it comes out and we're
going to be really
but mainly we're a fan channel i want to
know what you want to see so please jump
in the comments tell me what you think
of the video and tell me what sort of
video you want to see next
thanks and uh
see you next time
[Music]
you